so the audience of this podcast
may not know much about jiu jitsu
or they do because it's really part of
the culture now but they don't
really know much they see that so many
people have fallen in love with it have
been transformed through it but they
don't know much about like
what is this thing is there a way you
could sort of
try to explain the what is jiu jitsu
what is the essence of this martial art
that's
captured the minds and hearts of so many
people in the world
i think that jiu jitsu is is a
philosophy
that's expressed physically and that
it's
the kind of development of the in mental
capacity and physical capacity working
in
unison to uh
move efficiently and
almost flowingly unresistantly
with with a given situation with a with
or physically resisting opponent
um learning how to generate force
on your own and how to steal force from
the floor how to steal force from the
other person
and move in concert with it as opposed
to clash against which if you watch
two untrained people fight it's almost
entirely a clash it's a runaway and
clash or run away and clash
um if you watch jiu jitsu done well
it's it it looks like water moving
around a solid structure
and and i think that that is expressed
physically and i think that all of the
things
that anyone have really been able to do
very very well
in jiu jitsu end up kind of exemplifying
that
but i think that's true of martial arts
in general i think that a lot of times
like the
clashing that we see going on um and
working well is just the fact that you
know you get
very very physically powerful people
every now and then they're able to get
away with this but i don't think that
that's
and that's that's fantastic because
ultimately it's a results driven thing
but
i think that the essence of the martial
arts is learning how to make more out of
less and how to move with
and be yielding almost like real life
aikido
and uh so you think of martial arts uh
jiu jitsu
as uh like water
or flowing so aikido moving around
the the force as opposed to
sort of maybe the wrestling mindset is
finding a leverage where you can apply
an exceptional amount of force
so like it's like maximizing the
application of force i guess maybe
that's a better way to i'd like to marry
the two ideas you know because i think
you flow until the point at which you
are the greater force at which point in
time you can apply
but if you look at the best wrestlers
and when i say best i don't necessarily
mean most successful although of course
most successful are always very very
good
um throughout the course of history in
boxing in
wrestling in judo um they're magical
they they disappear and reappear it's
like fighting a ghost that that
is like incorporeal when you want to
find it but then when you don't want it
to find it
when you don't want to find it it finds
you and uh i think that we see that
in the like the bouvis bouvie societies
of wrestling
um and you know i guess you could look
at uh floyd mayweather or willie pep
or uh you know pernell whitaker in
boxing um as brilliant examples of
disappearing and reappearing and when
you're strong it's almost like guerrilla
warfare
when you're strong i'm nowhere to be
found when you're weak you can't get rid
of me
and i think that's what we're looking
for yeah the tear brothers are
incredible at that they just
they they look like a skinny starbucks
baristas
and uh they just manhandle
everybody like effortlessly they look
like they just kind of woke up
yeah rolled out of bed fighting for like
the
the gold medal at the olympics and just
effortlessly throw
uh like there's a match against you i
guess yo romero
yeah so like you you know if you look at
like who is the guy
who's like intimidating in this case uh
and the terrifying looking it's
uh it's it's yo romero just like a
physical specimen and obviously like a
super accomplished wrestler
i think this is for the gold medal yeah
in 2000
2000 yeah cindy and then they're this is
the year you all took silver
and what you like just to just show you
like there's a
inside trip effortless gucci
and he does it again yep
you know it's a really creative kind of
wrestling where
it's organic yeah you're throwing all
these kinds of things it's just a mix of
judo a mix of
like weird kind of moves it's not like
as funky as uh ben askren it's
it's just like legitimate basic
well it's not funky for funky's sake and
i'm not not poking right ben asking
to imply that that's what he's doing but
it's like it's funny it's like a lot of
times it's almost like a
talked a lot about that you know that
the only goal of combat is
to win is the the outcome is it's
outcome driven versus like flourishing
you know cool looking movements it's
like unless that had a utilitarian
purpose like what are you wasting your
time with that
both in the fight and also you know in
practice but but as you mentioned it's
almost like it looks like judo it looks
like wrestling it looks like jiu jitsu
it's almost like i guess
reminds me all of the martial arts is
again deeply tribal as well i
i want to learn lex friedman martial
arts and then i want to learn
another you know i guess transcendent
person's martial arts and it just
happened to be the set of movements that
you tended to do most of the time
thanks to your body type and your
opposition and whatnot but then i try to
codify that and force those to work as
opposed to going i want to understand
how the body works in concert and in in
congress with something else and other
forces
and move appropriately and that's why
it's like it always struck me that the
sightseeing brothers are great examples
of
just moving like water but they to use
bruce lee which is a little trite but
again he's brilliant it's like
water can flow or what it can crash and
they would crash when they needed to
crash and they would flow when they
needed to flow but they would flow for
the purpose of dissipating and then
crash when they would win
and at the right moment then go back to
flowing the second that the other person
found them and it's just
it's beautiful to watch it's artistic
and i think that that great expression
of anything
physical is ultimately studied as a
science but expressed as an art and i
think that that's something that gets
lost in jiu jitsu a lot of times when it
gets a little bit
a little nerdy like do this hand to your
hand here like it's like the more
details i have the better
when in reality that's just not not in
my experience how it's done
you